all right so shifting gears here we're
talking about new york city now let's
talk about
texas what the hell is going on in our
former home state of texas
so more than 2.8 million texans are
without power as the state battles an
unprecedented winter storm well the
entire country is
battling a winter storm but it seems
like texas right now is the porsche
child for what the hell is weather is
doing
so frigid temperatures in texas are
causing a surge in electricity demand
and leading to rolling
power blackouts across the countries
across the country's second largest
state which prompted
president joe biden to declare a state
of emergency
in texas earlier this week at least 2.8
million texans have experienced power
outages
as of 2 p.m local time that was monday
when hurricane harvey a category 4 storm
made landfall in texas four years ago
almost 400
000 texans lost power so look at those
numbers 400 000 during a hurricane
and now almost 3 million
right now in texas the national weather
service tweeted
uh early monday morning earlier this
week that the temperature at its base
had reached
minus two degrees fahrenheit the coldest
temperature recorded in over 32 years it
is currently
negative two degrees fahrenheit
in texas we got out justin
just in time kai what the hell is going
on in texas bro
no i definitely think this is crazy um
and last time they recorded
temperatures like this i think it was in
1930s and then
right around 1900 so i mean obviously
it's unprecedented if we see here what
mario pulled up um
texas uh top area with by outages
496 000 homes you're looking at
as of last night 2.7 million people were
still without uh power
which is just wild now why
taxes in taxes now why is this happening
uh
from what i've been reading it's a lot
of that texas is on its own power grid
and that power grid has been having
issues uh and given that it's its own
system they can't just lend excess power
coming from
other states the same way as normally
yeah if this happens in another state
they can like
take in power from another state they
come in and help they can't do it
they're isolated in texas they have
their own grid so we always hear stories
about
texas is going to secede from the union
yeah texas is his own republic
texas to do what it wants not today
what's up now texas
like it wasn't as easy it's not like we
we always hear stories i i haven't heard
that in a in a long time so where where
do you hear these stories
where do you hear what stories wants to
explain what do you mean this was like
the story like
we covered this on the podcast ago these
stories i don't hear that often but it
does come up but i don't hear that often
this one we covered this did we not
cover this on the pot this what was the
big story in the news about texas a few
months ago
right before the election possibility of
succeeding they were thinking about it
governor abbott
one time are you defending texas i'm
defending today i'm a former texas buddy
you're a florida boy now
you enjoyed this 80 degree weather okay
you want i'll show you a few months
i will ship you back to texas negative
two degrees there'll be a guatemalan in
texas
with no boots on they'll have a city no
boots on the ground
did you guys hear what uh what elon musk
tweeted so the uh the texas electrical
grid operator
is called electric reliability council
of texas the e-r-c-o-t
and elon musk tweets out they're not
earning that r
for reliability because all the power's
out um not exactly an endorsement but
this is a serious serious issue i mean i
i wonder how many people have died i
mean i i feel old people how are you
checking on old people in this i mean i
don't know
your uncle but how i mean what's going
on it's a wood-burning stove so they're
or a wood-burning
fireplace so they're okay they could
crank up some heat um
you know tesla's i i guess you show some
images like actual images of what
dallas looks like or houston looks like
of what houston had snow
the snow i mean this is on we'd never
see something like that i remember
one time because i was living in texas
in dallas from
one afternoon one sunday afternoon it
started snowing yeah
and as soon as it came it just melted
but i was like oh what's going on here
this is what texas looks like right now
yeah
this looks like it's freaking
minneapolis right here tom's hometown
right
looks like it's minneapolis look at this
look what that's tigran's backyard
yeah and the problem in a city like
texas ring valley road that's right by
the office belt line literally
beltline road i lived on belt last road
i i
you know what i did you know this this
might have helped um
keep people warm i left my apartment i
burned that [ __ ] to the ground
i said i'm out of this apartment i will
never be at this building again
v v and m they're coming after me for uh
they actually pulled off they built a
soy man
a snowman a soy man nice well played
well played
but but bottom line is we are thinking
about our friends in texas
yep generally we're thinking about all
our friends
at php we're thinking about uh you know
people who are suffering through this
definitely cold weather right now we're
looking not used to this and we're
rooting for it
wholesale price of electricity in
houston went from 22
a megawatt hour to 9 000. yeah their
natural gas supply has been cut off and
imagine
your home and your power goes off for 10
minutes you freak out
so my hearts are with everybody in texas
that are dealing with this right now i
hope it gets turned around quickly
i hope they can fix this reliability
grid that they have because it it has in
the issues
because at some point this weather will
return and you just can't have this
not in a state as progressive as texas
it affects so many lives and plus when
you have snow like this
these cities aren't equipped with snow
plows minneapolis can handle it
milwaukee can handle it infrastructure
dallas california
yeah it's impossible caught off guard
caught off guard and enough of the
the seceding talk all right we don't
want to piss mario off with that but
that was a one-time thing apparently
enough of this okay and you wonder like
elon musk sends out that
that tweet i wonder if he now granted
you know you just don't make a
fly-by-night decision say i'm moving to
texas you have to think that through but
this doesn't help the recruiting right
for the people that are moving to texas
yeah i mean it exposes the fact that you
know what it says there is
this house recruiting to florida you
might not look like the best state in
the union right now
as of now as of now wow
it's hard guys we did it we got to
florida well i i didn't agree yet
i mean sport is great i mean it's fun
are you going to say california you've
been talking trash about
we california know guys that was this is
the uh the bet david podcast
we are thinking of our fearless leader
and ceo patrick bett david
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye